[Music]
well another tragedy will we ever learn
on a day like today it's pointless to
even post on social media but I
absolutely must I can't and I won't and
I cannot and I will not stay silent as
an American as an amateur stand-up
comedian as a privileged person who
recognizes my own privilege it is my
duty to speak out admit it
you're all just posting on social media
for the attention today is not about me
share my post if you agree
[Music]
[Laughter]
today has deeply affected me personally
my thoughts and prayers are with victims
of this horrendous tragedy we have to
fight fire with peace fire sure my post
if you agree just watch tomorrow you'll
go back to posting selfies and forget
this tragedy ever happened
[Music]
feels good to say something it really
does